hello everyone and welcome to a game we
said that we would cover after the
previous one I hope you enjoyed that
game between Brazil robber and Miguel my
dwarf also it's a game from the intra
zonal tournament in sweden goetaborg in
1955 it's a tournament
it's a 21 player round-robin where 9 and
9 of the most successful players will
qualify for the 1956 candidates
tournament in amsterdam but as we
already mentioned all of this let's
check out this game before we check it
out I do have a nice photo challenge
it's it's a photo challenge but also
kind of an introduction to this
tournament here is a photo of all the
players that played in this tournament
and it will be also a very nice
challenge for you because it's not a
very good photo so I think you should be
able to spot at least 10 players you can
recognize but you know feel free feel
free to test your vast knowledge here
and you know if any if anyone can call
all 21 of them then do share in the
comments of course and do share how many
of you did you recognise and just for
comparison this photo from 1955 here is
a photo of Real Madrid team it's a photo
from 1957 ok that it's some somewhat 2
years of a difference but there you can
see that you know even in those days
they had nice cameras only only not for
chess so here we have this one again now
let's go back to this one and the chess
one again so I just wanted to put that
out there and we do have a nice photo of
this game in particular here it is Paul
Karras on the left and Boris Spassky on
the right is photo from at the previous
videos photo challenge a lot of you got
it right since yes there is a riding
with players names on it so yeah and
you've already seen the standings after
the tournament but we're gonna check it
out once more after this game so we have
Paul Harris with the white pieces he
opens with d4 Knight to f6 c4 e6 Knight
to f3 and B 6 Spassky goes for the
Queen's Indian defense these were the
good old days before alpha0 ruined the
Queen's Indian defense for everyone so
of course Spassky goes for it and we
have III Karras plays the Spassky
variation
against the Queen's Indian the Spassky
system Bishop to b7 we have Bishop to d3
and Bishop to e7 now both players Castle
b3 now preparing to fianchetto the dark
square Bishop d5 Bishop to b2 9b d7
Knight to c3 c5 now o players simply
developing pieces
Queeny to connecting groups developing
the Queen now first the captors on c4 b
captures and Queen to c7 black also now
connected rooks rook a to d1 we have
rook 888 and now you could continue the
game simply bring the other rook to a
useful square but here Karis plays a
better move the immediate d5 now the
immediate the d5 if you can grab more
space it's as a general principle you
should always do it as capturing on d5
is not so simple if if as possibly
decided to capture here then after C
captures on d5 Knight captures you get
the special characters on h7 move it's
nothing all that too dangerous but after
keen captures Knight captures on b5
Bishop captures rook captures the
material on the board is completely
equal but who would you rather play here
black or white this bishop here is a
complete monster this rook can come to
the attack via g5 h5 a knight is coming
to the game the Queen can easily be
shifted into the attack
so although the material is equal and
white is a bit better here it would be
very unpleasant to play this for black
so after d5 would have a 6 by Spassky D
captures on e6 and F captors on e6
so without being able to actually
capture on d5 now Karis created a nice
isolated pawn on e6 and it will become a
target we are for example Knight g5 so
95 immediately we have Queen to c6 now
the threat is well for now not possible
because Queen to g2 would be checkmate
so you do have to prevent this we have
f4 now the Queen from e2 is also
guarding protecting white foam beam
checkmated h h6 kicking the knight back
from such a nice square Knight goes back
to f3 and Queen to c7 now we have nice
to h5 going for that very nice g6 where
where well either just gonna keep the
night there but you can also destroy
black special pair so much it could be
six Spassky doesn't allow this we have
pushed back to be one and now rook F to
e 8 and now nice G 6 will be a nice
square for the night but at least it
will not come with tempo Queen to F 2
are preparing to bring the Queen over to
g3 to help out with the attack against
the black king but also getting it out
of a file that the rook is controlling
nice - f8 now not allowing carest to get
his knight all the way to g6 we have
Queen to g3 nice to h5 now attacking the
Queen Queen to h3 and now Knight back to
f6 saying do you do want to draw or or
do you want to keep playing this game if
if spots if curse would repeat Queen to
g3 then probably Spassky will again
repeat Knight to h5 and we would have a
draw by threefold repetition but Harris
is up for a fight so nice to g6 we have
E 5 now the strongest continuation we
have nice to d5 attacking the Queen and
here Knight d5 is an excellent move by
carats because now you have to capture
the knight moving the Queen is it's
pretty bad because if you play something
like it knows something like night the
Queen to d7 trying to exchange Queens
then Bishop to f5 would be would be
crushing for white but even the straight
forward Queen captures and h6 would be
deadly
now of course if you don't capture the
Queen then you're just down in the
material and you're you're getting
crushed and if you do capture the Queen
then comes knife captures on f6
now the king is in check the Queen is
forked after King moves you get Knight
capture 77 now after rook captures and
e7f captures on e5 Bishop captures only
5 now you have Bishop captures an e5
this comes with check and after rook
captures Knight captures on e5 and white
is up a whole rope here so that would
definitely be terrible so after Knight
to d5 we have Bishop captures on d5
capturing that that powerful Knight F
captures on e5
first a nice in-between move or swishing
tool if you will if you can open light
wise to
towards the black King you definitely
should as those bishop those bishops on
and b1 and b2 are monsters but you do
have to you know let let them out out of
their their cages so butter captures
only five not captures on e5 and now
Bishop to e6 getting the bishop out of
danger and Queen to g3 now we have
Brooke after sandy one rope capture
sandy won and now b5 and here
caris brings the rook back to f1 rock to
f1 now the threat again being rook
captures knight on f6 as of course the G
pawn is pinned as the Queen occupies the
g3 Square and here with Knight 8 to h7
protecting this Knight the game would go
on white is of course still better the
bishop pair those guys are monsters the
night is beautiful placed here all of
Paul Kara's pieces are our ideally
placed so to say and would move like
this the game could continue but after
this rook to f1 Spassky makes a terrible
mistake
instead of guarding the night from h7 he
decides to guard the night from d7 seems
like seems like the idea is the same and
also it too now immediately threatens to
exchange more pieces but sorry I meant
nice 2d this Knight to d7 he didn't
defend tonight with this night out
writer he simply moved the night and now
offered to to exchange pieces but this
move is a terrible blunder and Spassky
really makes quick carries really makes
a quick work of Spassky now so feel free
to pause the video here and find the
move that immediately wins the white the
game as usual I will give it a couple of
seconds so you know feel free to feel
free to really study the position here
so for those you who found it
congratulations you are you are an
excellent attacker and for those who
just want to enjoy the show
here Karis played Queen captures on g7
and of course once possibly saw this he
immediately resigned the game as of
course now you see what's happening the
bishops are now completely completely
alive and after queen cap King captors
Queen which is the only move now you get
the force variation of the knight
capture Sun d7 opening
I discovered attack from this Bishop
King has to move doesn't really matter
all that much either we will block with
the Queen end and the same thing follows
or you move the King and then again
Knight to f6 check and now it doesn't
really matter what you play if you go
King to g7 then you get Knights to g4
check King moves and the Knight captures
on h6 will be checkmate and if instead
after this second Knight f6 check you go
King to f7 then comes Knight to d5 check
simply checking the King and of course
the Queen is now under attack King moves
Knight captures Queen and now it's all
over
whatever-whatever black plays simply a
nice exchange of pieces and now White
has three pieces against the rook it's a
completely winning position of course so
after this spectacular move Karis played
after spassky's blonder pink a person g7
as poss he resigned at the game and
moved there is unmoved 30 so another
nice game from this very nice tournament
the Gothenburg inter-zonal tournament of
1955 I do hope you enjoyed it and it's
you know those tournaments are or you
know a great piece of chess history and
all of the games are very excited
exciting as all the players are you know
they're really exciting players and
their games you know we're really great
so best of luck to everyone good that
photo challenge and I know we've seen
the final standings in the previous
video but it's always nice to check out
the final standings so once again here
are the final standings of the
Gothenburg in Toronto tournament as you
as you all know by now from that one
video that branched and really
obliterated the field with 15 out of 20
that's 10 wins 0 losses in 10 draws Paul
Karras second place as usual that's
that's why I put the quote by Karras as
he says I was unlucky like my country
then Oscar panel in fourth place Stephen
Barton which Petrosyan FM Geller as well
as law Sabo and miroslav Philip and then
Boris Spassky in eighth place so
definitely Boris Spassky also qualified
for the 1956 tournament in in Amsterdam
but you all know who won the 1956
tournament in Amsterdam but yeah I don't
think I will continue the series
for this tournament like immediately but
at some point already this created my
playlist so when I do continue it we
will already have two games to begin
with I would like to thank qawalli and
the norman beret for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it
norman beret is 61 years old and he says
that he's not very good at chess but he
is very eager to learn so I'm extremely
happy to hear that so best of luck to
mr. norman and on a sidenote
completely non chess related I'm reading
a very nice book now I will not tell you
which book is it but I really enjoy it
very much
and when I finish it I will make a short
review about it so you can check it out
and maybe consider you know checking out
the book yourselves so once again thank
you all as usual you can check to my
previous videos here and yeah I will see
you soon